saludos Rosa en la agenda de esa visita
oficial hay varios desafíos primordial
la reanudación de la cooperación
económica macron viaja junto a
empresarios franceses que representan la
cerca de 2.000 empresas presentes en
suelo chino habrá énfasis en la
seguridad de los negocios perjudicados
aún por las restricciones sanitarias de
Pekín en los últimos tres años una
importantísima señal política macron
estará acompañado este jueves por la
presidenta de la comisión europea esa
iniciativa es coherente con su visión de
negociar como bloque para obtener
mayores beneficios para todos los países
miembros una vez más se desmarca del
canciller federal alemán Olaf shores
quien viajó a China solo y sin mayores
concertaciones con los países de la
Unión Europea A fines del año pasado un
punto esencial la guerra en Ucrania
Francia considera a China como actor
fundamental para el retorno de la paz y
macron achí como uno de los pocos
líderes que puede influir sobre Vladimir
Putin
en este fragmento de un comunicado del
Eliseo apoyar militarmente a Rusia sería
una decisión desastrosa un mensaje que
sin duda macrón pasará a su par
comunista habrá también referencia a los
uigures la comunidad musulmana que Pekín
mantiene en campamentos de reeducación y
a la seguridad en el estrecho de Taiwán
Luis Miguel y precisamente la guerra en
Ucrania no central en el tablero
geopolítico de hoy ha llevado a Francia
a aumentar su presupuesto de defensa Y
es que hoy de hecho se presentó ante el
consejo de ministros la ley que regula
este rearmamiento Qué cambios contiene
este texto
el núcleo de la ley de programación
militar presentada Hoy es el incremento
del presupuesto del ejército francés de
entre tres y cuatro mil millones de
euros anuales hasta llegar a 69 mil
millones en 2030 esto es más del doble
del período anterior y todo junto es
decir el presupuesto de base más este
aumento del que hablamos suma
413 mil millones de euros incluyendo
unos 13 mil millones que financiarán la
ayuda militar a Ucrania en concreto que
se hará con ese dinero la dotación más
importante se destinará a mantener los
equipos existentes listos para enfrentar
un conflicto de alta intensidad segunda
partida presupuestaria la reconstitución
del stock de municiones o la adquisición
de nuevas armas como misiles antibuque
de largo alcance o misiles aire tierra
de Nueva Generación importante el
presupuesto prevé la construcción de un
nuevo portaaviones de propulsión nuclear
que debe estar listo en 2036 y
operacional en 2038